you may or may not be aware that Donald
Trump is suffering yet another major
loss to his administration this time
it's the Director of National
Intelligence dan coats coats is
resigning and as usual there's this
question of whether is it really a
resignation or is it a firing because
Trump's relationship with the
intelligence community has been pretty
disastrous since day one and Dan Coates
is one of those people who when he
testifies before Congress and has asked
basic questions like did Russia
interfere in our elections he goes with
what the evidence has told the
intelligence community the answer is yes
that's not a position that Donald Trump
likes and it appears as though removing
Dan Coates is yet another way to pave
the way to not stop foreign interference
in 2020 to ignore the attacks on our
democratic systems which is exactly what
Donald Trump and Mitch McConnell have
made it super clear they want to be
doing for 2020 Mitch McConnell getting
in the way of every bill or proposal
meant to stop foreign interference in
our elections so Coates is going out
Trump has nominated Republican
Congressman John Ratcliffe who truly
knows nothing about being the Director
of National Intelligence and has no
business being the DNI this is I mean
language starts to lose its meaning it's
a stunning choice and to call something
stunning in the Trump administration the
Trump era is a sort of limited meaning
since we are stunned day after day
Democratic Senator Ron Wyden is calling
him the least qualified individual ever
to be nominated to be DNI and says that
Ratcliffe could straight-up put people
people's lives at risk
check out a couple of tweets where Ron
Wyden says congressman Ratcliffe is the
most partisan and least qualified
individual ever nominated to serve as
DNI his only qualifications seem to be
promoting Trump's conspiracy theories
about the investigation into Russian
interference and calling for prosecution
of Trump's political enemies continuing
he has endorsed widespread government
surveillance and shown little concern
for Americans rights
except for those of Trump and his close
associates confirming this individual
would amount to an endorsement of this
administration strive to politicize our
intelligence agencies putting in place a
Director of National Intelligence who
has repeated baseless conspiracy
theories about the Russia probe that
have been widely debunked by the
intelligence community is disgusting and
embarrassing
he senselessly and embarrassingly
berated former special prosecutor Robert
Muller last week during the
congressional testimony if you wanted to
destroy the American intelligence
apparatus from the inside out if you
have the goal of weakening our
intelligence community this is exactly
who you would select a Republican
conspiracy theorist who has spread fake
news and false intelligence it is really
difficult to be less qualified than
Donald Trump's education secretary Betsy
Davos and yet here we are I think that
this guy actually surpasses Betsy DeVos
has not qualified for his position and
when you look at the reaction of this
from foreign intelligence agencies the
intelligence agencies of foreign nations
are drooling about this because it will
laughably weak in the United States it
will make us more vulnerable and I wish
I could say that our Senate will do its
job and prevent this clown from being
confirmed to the role I don't know that
they will I don't know that they will
remember that Republicans control the
Senate and the state control the
committees that ultimately decide about
these nominations and I don't know that
they are going to put a stop to this
it's disgusting it's embarrassing it is
a hand out to our adversaries but it
seems to be a feature of Donald Trump's
election not a bug that this is a guy
that would effectively unwind the
intelligence community from the inside
out and the world is laughing and your
life and my life and the lives of so
many people in this country are
potentially at risk as a result of this
choice Trump will probably get his guy
in there we'll take a quick break and be
back after this
I am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
asam / Pakman blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka Steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
/ Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link in the description I
have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink is calm / Pakman that's B Li NK
is t.com /pa ke ma n